hello everyone welcome to CS 2 to 9
today we're going to talk about deep
learning and neural networks we're going
to have two lectures on that one today
and a little bit more of it on Monday
don't hesitate to ask questions during
the lecture so stop me if you don't
understand something and we'll try to
build the intuition around your own
Network together we will actually start
with an algorithm that you guys have
seen previously called logistic
regression everybody remembers logistic
regression ok remember it's a
classification algorithm we're going to
do that
explain how logistic regression can be
interpreted as a neural network specific
case of a neural network and then we
will go to neural networks sounds good
so the quick intro and deep learning so
deep learning is a is a set of
techniques that is let's say a subset of
machine learning and it's one of the
growing techniques that have been used
in the industry specifically for
problems in computer vision natural
language processing and speech
recognition so you guys have a lot of
different tools and and plugins on your
smartphones that uses this type of
algorithm the reason it came to work
very well is primarily the new
computational methods so one thing we're
going to see today is that deep learning
is really really computationally
expensive and people had to find
techniques in order to parallelize the
code and use GPU specifically in order
to graphical processing unit in order to
be able to compute the computations in
the punic the second part is the data
available has been growing after after
the internet bubble with the
digitalization of the work so now people
have access to large amounts of data and
this type of algorithm has the
specificity of be able to learn
when there's a lot of data so these
models are very flexible and the more
you give them data the more they will be
able to understand the salient feature
of the data and finally algorithms so
people have come up with with new
techniques in order to use the data use
the competition power and build models
so we're going to touch a little bit on
all of that but let's go with logistic
regression first can you guys see in the
back yeah okay so you remember what
logistic regression is we're going to
fix a goal for us that is a
classification goal so let's try to to
find cuts in images so find cuts in
images meaning binary classification if
there is a cut in the image we want to
output a number that is close to one
presence of the cut and if there is no
cut in the image one output zero let's
say for now we're constrained to the
fact that there is maximum one cut very
much there's no more if you have to draw
the logistic regression model that's
what you would do you would take a cut
so this is an image of the cuts very bad
at that sorry in computer science you
know that images can be represented as
3d matrices so if I tell you that this
is a color image of size 64 by 64 how
many numbers do I have to represent
those pixels
yeah I heard it 64 by 64 by 3:3 for the
RGB Channel red green blue every pixel
in an image can be represented by three
numbers one represents in the red filter
the green filter and the blue filter so
actually this image is of size 64 times
64 times 3 that make sense so the first
thing we will do in order to use
logistic regression to find if there is
a cut on this image we're going to
flatten this into a vector so I'm going
to take all the numbers in this matrix
and flatten them in a vector just an
image to vector operation nothing more
and now I can use my logistic regression
because I have a vector input so I'm
going to to take all of these and push
them in an operation let me call this in
the logistic operation which has one
part that is W X plus B where X is going
to be the image so W X plus B and the
second part is going to be the sigmoid
everybody's familiar with the sigmoid
function function that takes a number
between minus infinity and plus infinity
maps it between 0 and 1 it's very
convenient for classification problems
and this we're going to call it Y hat
which is sigmoid of what you've seen in
class previously I think it's theta
transpose X but here we will just
separate the notation into W and B so
can someone tell me what's the shape of
W 2 matrix W vector matrix
what
yeah 64 by 64 by 3 as a yeah so you know
that this guy here is a vector of 64 by
64 by 3 a column vector so the shape of
X is going to be 64 by 64 by 3 times 1
this is the shape and this I think it's
twelve twelve thousand 288 and this
indeed because we want Y hat to be one
by one this W has to be one by twelve
298 that make sense so we have a row
vector as our parameter we're just
changing the notations of the logistic
regression that you guys have seen and
so once we have this model we need to
train it as you know and the process of
training is that first we will
initialize or parameters these are what
we call parameters we will use the
specific vocabulary of weights and bias
I believe you guys have heard this
vocabulary before weights and biases so
we're going to find the right W and the
right B in order to be able to use this
model properly once we initialize them
what we will do is that we will optimize
them find the optimal W and B and after
we found the optimal W and B we will use
them to predict
does this process make sense this
training process and I think the
important part is to understand what
this is find the optimal W and B means
defining your last function which is the
objective and in machine learning you
often have this this specific problem
where you have a function that you know
you want to find the network function
but you don't know the values of its
parameters in order to find them you're
going to use a proxy that is going to be
your last function if you manage to
minimize the last function you will find
the right parameters so you define a
loss function that is the logistic loss
Y log Y hat plus 1 minus y log of 1
minus y hat you guys have seen this one
you remember where it comes from comes
from a maximum likelihood estimation
starting from a probabilistic model and
so the idea is how can I minimize this
function minimize because I've put a
minus sign here I want to find W and B
that minimize this function and I'm
going to use a gradient descent
algorithm which means I'm going to
iteratively compute the derivative of
the loss with respect to my parameters
and at every step I will update them to
make this loss function go a little down
at every trait if set so in terms of
implementation this is a for loop you
will loop over a certain number of
iteration and at every point you will
compute the derivative of your loss with
respect to your parameters everybody
remembers how to compute this number
take the derivative here you use the
fact that the sigmoid function has a
derivative that is Sigma 8 times 1 minus
Sigma and you will compute the results
we're going to do some derivative later
today but just to set up the problem
here so the few things that I want to do
I want to touch on here is first how
many parameters does
this model have this logistic regression
if you have to count them so this is the
number 89 yeah correct so twelve
thousand two hundred eighty eight
weights and one bias that make sense so
actually it's funny because you can
quickly count it by just counting the
number of edges on the on the on the
drawing plus one every circle has a bias
every Edge has a weight because
ultimately this operation you can
rewrite it like that right it means
every weight has every weight
corresponds to an edge so that's another
way to count it we're going to use it a
little further so we're starting with
not too many parameters actually and one
thing that we noticed is that the number
of parameters of our model depends on
the size of the input we probably don't
want that at some point so we're going
to change it later so two equations that
I want you to remember is the first one
is neurone equals linear plus activation
so this is the vocabulary we will use in
your networks we define in your own as
an operation that has two parts one
linear part and one activation part and
it's exactly that this is actually a
neural we have a linear part WX plus B
and then we take the output of this
linear part and we put it in an
activation that in this case is the
sigmoid function it can be other
functions okay so this is the first
equation not too hard the second
equation that I wanna set now is the
model equals architecture plus
parameters what does that mean it means
here we're trying to train a logistic
regression in order to be able to use it
we need an architecture which is the
following a one-year own neural network
and the parameters W and E so basically
when people say we've shipped a model
like in the industry what they're saying
is that they found the right parameters
with the right architecture they have
two files and these two files are
predicting a bunch of things okay one
parameter file and one architecture file
the architecture will be modified a lot
today we will add neurons all over and
the parameters will always be called W
and B but they will become bigger and
bigger because we have more data we want
to be able to understand it you can get
that it's going to be hard to understand
what a cat is with only that that that
many parameters we want to have more
parameters any questions so far so this
was just to set up the problem with
logistic regression let's try to set a
new goal after the first goal we have
set prior to that so the second goal
would be find cat lion so a little
different than before only thing we
changed is that we want to now to detect
three types of animals if there's a cat
on the image I want to know there is a
cat if there is anyone on the image I
want to know there is an iguana if
there's a line on image I want to know
it as well so how would you modify the
network that we previously had in order
to take this into account yeah
yeah good idea so put two more circles
so neurons and do the same thing so we
have our picture here with the cats
so the cat is going to the right 64 by
64 by 3 we flatten it from X 1 to X n
let's say and represent 64 64 by 3 and
what I will do is that I will use 3
neurons that are all computing the same
thing they're all connected to all these
inputs ok I connect all my inputs x1 to
xn to each of these neurons and I will
use a specific set of notation here
why to hat equals a 2-1 sigmoid of w2 1
plus 2 and similarly white 3 hat equals
81 which is sigmoid of w3 1x plus 3 so
I'm introducing a few notations here and
we will get used to it don't worry so
just just write this down and we're
going to go over it so the square
brackets here represents what we will
call later on a layer if you look at
this network it looks like there is one
layer here there is one layer in which
neurons don't communicate with each
other we could add up to it and we will
do it later on more neurons in other
layers we will then note with square
brackets the index of the layer the
index that is the subscript to this a is
the number identifying the neuron inside
the layer so here we have one layer we
have a 1 a 2 and a 3 with square
brackets one to identify the layer does
it make sense and then we have our Y hat
that instead of being a single number as
it was before is now a vector of size 3
so how many parameters does this network
have
how much
okay how did you come up with that okay
yeah correct so we just have three times
the thing we had before because we added
two more neurons and they all have their
own set of parameters look like this
edge is a separate edges this one so we
have to replicate parameters for each of
these so w11 would be the equivalent of
what we had for the cat but we have to
add two more parameter vectors and
biases so other question when you have
to train this logistic regression what
data set did you need
can someone try to describe the data set
yeah yeah correct so we need images and
labels with it's labeled as cat one or
no cat zero so it's a binary
classification with images and labels
now what do you think should be the data
set to train this network yes that's a
good idea
so just to repeat a label for an image
that has a cat would probably be a
vector with a one and two zeroes where
the one should represent the present the
presence of a cat this one should
represent the presence of a lion and
this one should represent the presence
of an iguana so let's assume I use this
scheme to label my dataset I train this
network using the same techniques here
initialize all my weights and biases
with a value a starting value optimize a
loss function by using gradient descent
and then use y hat equals lala to
predict what do you think this neuron is
going to be responsible for if you have
to describe the responsibilities of this
neuro yes well this one yeah lion and
this one iguana so basically the way you
go free that's a good question
we're going to talk about that now
multiple image contain different animals
or not so going back on what you said
because we decided to label our data set
like that after training this neuron is
not really going to be there to detect
cuts if we had changed the labeling
scheme and I said that the second entry
would correspond to the
shut the presence of the cat then after
training you will detect that this
neuron is responsible for detecting the
cat so the network is going to evolve
depending on the way you label your
dataset
now do you think that this network can
still be robust to different animals in
the same picture so this cat now has a
friend that is a lion okay I have no
idea how to draw a lion but let's say
there is a lion here and because there
is a lion I will add a one here do you
think this network is robust to this
type of labeling
hmm it should be the neurons aren't
talking to each other that's a good
answer actually another answer that's a
good on intuition because the network
what it sees is just one one zero and an
image it doesn't see that this one
corresponds to the Cal correspond to the
first one and the second and the line
correspond to the second one so this is
a property of neural networks it's the
fact that you don't need to tell them
everything if you have enough data
they're going to figure it out
so because you will have also cats with
iguanas cats alone Lions with iguanas
lions alone ultimately this neuron will
understand what it's looking for and it
will understand that this one
corresponds to this line just needs a
lot of data so yes it's going to be
robust and that's the reason you
mentioned is going to be robust to that
because the tree neurons aren't
communicating together so we can totally
train them independent independently
from each other and in fact the sigmoid
here doesn't depend on the sigmoid here
and doesn't depend on the same weight
here it means we can have one one and
one as an output yes question you could
you could you could think about it as
trilogies equations so we wouldn't call
that in your own network yet it's not
ready yet but it's a three neural
network or three logistic regression
with each other now following up on that
yeah go for it the question W and B are
related to what oh yeah so so usually
you would have theta transpose X which
is sum of theta I X I correct and what I
will split it is I will spit it in sum
of theta I X I plus theta 0 times 1 I'll
split it like that theta 0 would
correspond to be
and these data eyes would correspond to
Wis make sense one more question
good question that's the next thing
we're going to see so the question is a
follow-up on this is there cases where
we have a constraint where there is only
one possible outcome it means there is
no chat in Lyon there's either a cat or
a lion
there is no Guana in Lyon there's either
in iguana or line think about health
care there are many there are many
models that are made to detect if this
is skin disease is present on based on
cell microscopic images usually there is
no overlap between this is it means you
want to classify a specific this is
among a large number of diseases so this
model would still work but would not be
optimal because it's longer to Train
maybe one this is super super rare and
one of the neurons is never going to be
trained let's say you're working in a
zoo where there is only one in wanna and
there are thousands of lions and
thousands of cats this guy will never
train almost you know it would be super
hard to train this one so you want to
start with another model that where you
put the constraint that okay there is
only one disease that we want to predict
and let the model learn with all the
neurons learn together by creating
interaction between them have you guys
heard of soft max yes some of you I see
that okay so let's look at soft max a
little bit together so we set a new goal
now which is we add a constraint which
is unique animal on an image so at most
one animal on an image
so I'm going to modify the network a
little bit we have our chat and there is
no line on the image we flatten it and
now I'm going to use the same scheme
with the tree neurons a1 a2 a3 but as an
output what I'm going to use is an
exponent softmax function so let me be
more precise let me let me actually
introduce another notation to make it
easier as you know the neuron is a
linear part plus an activation so we're
going to introduce a notation for the
linear part I'm going to introduce z1 1
to represent the linear part of the
first neuron z11 two to introduce the
linear part of the second gyro
so now when neuron has two parts one
which compute Z and one which computes a
equals Samoyed Ozzy now I'm going to
remove all the activations and make
these these and I'm going to use the
specific formula
so this if you recall it's exactly the
softmax formula okay so now the network
we have can you guys see rates too small
too small okay I'm going to just write
this formula bigger and then you can
figure out the others I guess because e
of Z 3 1 divided by sum from J equals 1
2 3 of e exponential of ZK this one so
here is a for the third one if you are
doing it for the first one you will add
you just change this into a 2 into a 1
and for a second 1 into a 2 so why is
this formula interesting and why is it
not robust to this labeling scheme
anymore it's because the sum of the
outputs of this network have to sum up
to 1 you can try it if you sum the three
outputs you get the same thing in the
numerator and on the denominator and you
get one that makes sense
so instead of getting a probabilistic
output for each each of Y if each of Y
hat 1 Y had to I had 3 we will get a
probability distribution over all the
classes so it means we cannot get 0.7
0.6 0.1 telling us roughly that there is
probably a cat and a lion but no iguana
we have to sum these two one so it means
if there is no cut and no lion it means
there is very likely an iguana the three
probabilities are dependent on each
other and for this one we have to label
the following way 1 1 0 for a cat 0 1 0
for a lion or 0 0 1
for an iguana so this is called a
softmax multi-class network you assume
there is at least one of the three
classes otherwise you have to add a
fourth input that will represent absence
of animal but this way your assume there
is always one of these three animals on
every picture and how many parameters
does the network have the same as the
second one we still have three neurons
and although I didn't write it this Z 1
is equal to w1 1 X plus B 1 Z 2 thames
III same so there's 3 n plus 3
parameters so one question that we
didn't talk about is how do we train
these parameters these these parameters
the 3n plus 3 parameters how do we train
them you think this scheme will work or
not what's wrong what's wrong with this
scheme what's wrong with the last
function specifically
there's only two outcomes so in this
last function y is a number between 0 &
1 y hat same is a probability y is
either 0 or 1 y hat is between 0 & 1 so
it cannot match this labeling so we need
to modify the loss function so let's
call it loss trainer what I'm going to
do is I'm going to just sum it up for
the fingers
does this make sense so I'm just doing
three times this loss for each of the
neurons so we have exactly three times
this we sum them together and if you
train this last function you should be
able to train the three neurons that you
have and again talking about scarcity of
one of the classes if there is not many
in Guana then the third term of this sum
is not going to help this neuron train
towards detecting an iguana
it's going to push it to the technology
Juana any question on the last function
does this one make sense yeah yeah
usually that's what will happen is that
the output of this network once it's
trained is going to be a probability
distribution you will pick the maximum
of those and you will set it one and the
others to zero as your prediction one
more question yeah
if you use the two one if you use this
labeling skin-like one one zero for this
network what do you think it will happen
it will probably not work and the reason
is this sum is equal to two there's some
of these entries while the sum of this
entry is equal to one so you will never
be able to match the output to the input
to the label it makes sense
so what the network is probably going to
do is it's probably going to send this
one to one half this one to one half and
this one to zero probably which is not
what you want okay let's talk about the
last function for this softmax
regression because you know what's
interesting about this loss is if I take
this derivative derivative of the Lost
3m with respect to W to one you thing is
going to be harder than this derivative
then this one or no it's going to be
exactly the same because only one of
these three terms depends on W want to
it means the derivative of the two
others are zero so we're exactly at the
same complexity during the derivation
but this one you think if you try to
compute let's say we define a loss
function that corresponds roughly to
that if you try to compute the
derivative of the loss with respect to W
2 it will become much more complex
because this number the output here that
is going to impact the loss function
directly not only depends on the
parameters of W 2 it also depends on the
parents of W 1 and W 3 and same for this
put this output also depends on the
parameters W 2 doesn't make sense
because of this denominator so the
softmax regression needs a different
loss function and a different derivative
so the loss function will define is a
very common one in deep learning
is called the softmax first entropy
cross entropy loss i'm not going to into
the details of where it comes from but
you can get the intuition why
so it surprisingly looks like the binary
croissant the binary the logistic class
function the only difference is that we
will sum it up on all the on all the
classes now we will take a derivative of
something that looks like that later but
I'd say if you can try it at home on
this one it would be a good exercise
this way so this binary croissant ropey
loss is very likely to be used in
classification problems that are multi
class okay so this was the first part on
logistic regression types of networks
and I think we're ready now with the
notation that we introduced to jump on
to neural networks any question on this
first part before we move on so one
question I would have for you let's say
instead of trying to predict if there is
a cat or no cat we will trying to
predict the age of the cat based on the
image what would you change this network
instead of predicting one zero you want
to predict the age of the cat what are
the things you would change
yes okay so I repeat I I basically make
several output nodes where each of them
corresponds to one edge of cats so would
you use this network or the third one
would use the tree neurons your own
network or the softmax regression the
third one why you have a unique age you
cannot have two ages right so we would
use a soft max one because we want a
probability distribution along the edge
the age okay that makes sense that's a
good approach there is also another
approach which is using directly
regression to predict an age an age can
be between 0 and plus in feet not plus
infinity 0 in a certain number and so
let's say you want to do a regression
how would you modify your network change
the sigmoid the sigmoid puts the Z
between 0 & 1 we don't want this to
happen so I'd say we will change the
sigmoid into what function would you
change the Samoyed
yes so the second one you said was or to
get a plus-one type of distribution okay
so let's let's go with linear you
mentioned linear we could just use a
linear function right for the sigmoid
but this becomes a linear regression the
whole network becomes a linear
regression another one that is very
common in in deep learning is called the
rayleigh function it's a function that
is almost linear but for every input
that is negative it's equal to zero
because we cannot have negative age it
makes sense to use this one okay so this
is called rectified linear units really
it's a very common one in different now
what else would you change we talked
about linear regression you remember the
last function you were using a linear
regression what was it it was probably
one of these two y hat minus y just
comparison between the output label and
Y hats the prediction or it was the l2
loss Y hat minus y in l2 norm so that's
what we would use we would modify our
loss function to fit the regression type
of problem and the reason we would use
this loss instead of the one we have for
a regression test is because in
optimization the shape of this loss is
much easier to optimize for a regression
task than it is for a classification
task and vice versa not going to go into
the details of that but that's the
intuition ok let's go have fun with
neural networks
so we we stick to our first goal I've
given an image tell us if there is cat
or no cat this is one this is you but
now we're going to make a network a
little more complex we're going to add
some parameters so I get my teacher of
the cat cat is moving okay
and what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to put more neurons than before
maybe something like that
so using the same notation you see that
my square bracket here is 2 indicating
that there is a layer here which is the
second layer while this one is the first
air and this one is the third layer
everybody's up to speed with the
notations cool so now notice that when
you make a choice of architecture you
have to be careful of one thing is that
the output layer has to have the same
number of neurons as you want the number
of classes to be for a classification
and one for a regression so how many
parameters does need this network have
can someone quickly give me the thought
process so how much here
yeah like 3n plus 3 let's say
yeah correct so here you would have
three any weights plus three biases here
you would have two times three weights
plus two biases because you have three
neurons connected to two neurons and
here you will have two times one plus
one bias this is the total number of
characters so you see that we didn't add
too much parameters most of the
parameters are still in the input layer
let's define some vocabulary the first
word is layer layer denotes neurons that
are not connected to each other these
two neurons are not connected to each
other
these three neurons are not connected to
each other we call this cluster of
neurons a layer and this has three
layers we would use input layer to
define the first layer output layer to
define the third layer because it
directly sees the output and we would
call the second layer a hidden layer and
the reason we call it hidden is because
the input and the output are hidden from
this layer it means the only thing that
this layer sees as input is what's the
previous layer again it so it's an
abstraction of the inputs but it's not
the input doesn't make sense and say it
doesn't see the output it just gives
what it understood to the last neuron
that will compare the output to the
ground truth so now why our neural
network interesting and why do we call
this hidden layer is because if you
train this network on cats
classification with a lot of images of
cats you would notice that the first
layers are going to understand the
fundamental concepts of the image which
is the edges this neuron is going to be
able to detect this type of edges this
your own probably going to detect some
other type of edge this neuron may be
this type of edge then what's going to
happen is that this neuron are going to
communicate what they found on the image
to the next layers new
and this room is going to use the edges
that these guys found to figure out that
oh there is a their ears while this one
is going to figure out oh there is a
mouth and so on if you have several
neural and they're going to communicate
what they understood to the output
neuron that is going to construct the
face of the cat
based on what it received and be able to
tell if there is a cat or not
so the reason it's called hidden layer
is because we don't really know what
it's going to figure out but with enough
data it should understand very complex
information about the data the deeper
you go the more complex information the
neurons are able to understand let me
give you another example which is a
house prediction example house price
prediction
so let's assume that our inputs are
number of bedrooms size of the house zip
code and wealth of the neighborhood
let's say what we will build is a
network that has twin neurons in the
first layer and one your own in the
output layer so what's interesting is
that as a human if you were to build
this network and like hand engineer it
you would say that okay zip code and
wealth or or sorry zip code and wealth
are able to tell us about the school
quality in the neighborhood the quality
of the school that is next to the house
probably as a human you would say these
are probably good features to predict
that the zip code is going to tell us if
the neighborhood is walkable or not
probably the size and the number of
bedrooms is going to tell us what's the
size of the family that can fit in this
house and these three are probably
better information than these in order
to finally predict the price so that's a
way to hand engineer that by hand as a
human in order to give human knowledge
to the network to figure out the price
in practice what we do here is that we
use a fully connected layer fully
connected what does it mean it means
that we connect every input of a layer
every every input to the first layer
every output of the first layer to the
input of the third layer
here and so on so all the neurons among
like from one layer to another are
connected with each other what we're
saying is that we will let the network
figure these out we will net the neurons
of the first layer figure out what's
interesting for the second layer to make
the price prediction so we will not tell
these to the network instead we will
fully connect the network and so on
okay we'll fully connect the network and
let it figure out what are the
interesting features and often time the
network is going to be able better than
humans to find these what are the
features that are representative
sometimes you may hear neural networks
referred as blackbox models the reason
is we will not understand what this edge
would correspond to it's it's hard to
figure out that this neuron is detecting
a weighted average of the input features
does it make sense another word you
might hear is end to end learning the
reason we talk about end to end learning
is because we have an input a ground
truth and we don't constrain the network
in the middle we let it learn whatever
it has to learn and we call it end to
end learning because we're just training
based on the input and the output
let's delve more into the math of this
network the neural network that we have
here which has an input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer let's try to
write down the equations that run the
input and pour propagated through the
output we first have z1 that is the
linear part of the first layer that is
computed using w1 times X plus B then
this z1 is given to an activation let's
say it's sigmoid which is sigmoid of z1
z2 is then the linear part of the second
neuron which is going to take the output
of the previous layer multiplied by its
weights and add the bias the second
activation is going to take the sigmoid
of z2 and finally we have the third
layer which is going to multiply its
weights with the output of the layer
present in it and add its bias and
finally we have the third activation
which is simply the simulate so what is
interesting to notice between these
equations and the equations that we
wrote here is that we put everything in
matrices so it means this 8/3 that I
have here sorry this here for three
neurons I wrote three
here for three neurons in the second
layer I just wrote a single equation to
summarize it but the shape of these
things are going to be vectors so let's
go over the shapes let's try to define
them z11 is going to be X which is n by
1 times W which has to be 3 by n because
it connects three neurons to the input
so this Z has to be 3 by 1 it makes
sense because we have three neurons
now let's go let's go deeper a 1 is just
the sigmoid of z1 so it doesn't change
the shape it keeps the 3 by 1 Z 2 we
know it it has to be 2 by 1 because
there are two neurons in the second
layer and it helps us figure out what W
2 would be we know a 1 is 3 by 1 it
means that W 2 has to be 2 by 3 and if
you count the edges between the first
and the second layer here you will find
6 ages 2 times 3 a 2 same shape as z2 z3
1 by 1 a 3 1 by 1 w3 it has to be 1 by 2
because a 2 is 2 by it's same for me B
is going to be the number of neurons so
3 by 1 2 by 1 and finally 1 by 1 so I
think it's usually very helpful even
when coding this type of equations to
know all the shapes that are involved
are you guys like totally ok with the
shapes super easy to figure out ok cool
so now what is interesting is that we
will try to vectorize the code even more
does someone remember the difference
between stochastic gradient descent and
gradient descent what's the difference
exactly so Cassie gradient descent is
update the weights and the bias after
you see every example so the direction
of the gradient is quite noisy doesn't
represent very well the entire batch
while gradient descent or batch gradient
descent is update after you've seen the
whole batch of examples and the gradient
is much more precise it points to the
direction you want to go to so what
we're trying to do now is to write down
these equations if instead of giving one
single cat image we had given a bunch of
images that either have a cat or another
cat so now our input X so what happens
for an input batch of examples so now
arm or X is not anymore a single column
vector it's a matrix with the first
image corresponding to X 1 the second
image corresponding to X 2 and so on
until the enth image corresponding to X
and I'm introducing a new notation which
is the parentheses superscript
corresponding to the ID of the example
so square brackets for the layer round
brackets for the idea of the example
we're talking about so just to give more
context on what we're trying to do we
know that this is a bunch of operations
we just have a network with inputs
hidden and output layer we could have a
network with a thousand layer the more
layers we have the more computation
and it quickly goes up so what we want
to do is to be able to paralyze our code
or our computation as much as possible
by giving batches of input and
parallelizing these equations so let's
see how these equations are modified
when we give it a bash of M inputs I
will use capital letters to denote the
equivalent of the lowercase letters but
for a batch of input so z1 as an example
would be w1 let's use the same w1 times
X plus b1 so let's analyze what z1 would
look like
z1 we know that for every for every
input example of the batch we will get
one Z 1 it should look like this
then we have to figure out what has to
be the shapes of this equation in order
to end up with this we know that Z one
was three by one it mean it means
Capital Z one has to be three by M
because each of these column vectors are
three by one and we have M of them
because for each input we forward
propagate through the network we get
these equations so for the first cut
image we get these equations for the
second cut image we get again equations
like that and so on so what is the shape
of X we have it above we know that it's
n by M what is the shape of W one it
didn't change the ability one doesn't
change it's not because I will give a
thousand inputs to my network that the
parameters are going to be more so the
parameter number stays the same even if
I give more inputs and so this has to be
3 by n in order to match now the
interesting thing is that there is a an
algebraic problem here what is the
algebraic problem we said that the
number of parameters doesn't change it
means that W has the same shape as it
has before as it had before B should
have the same shape as it had before
right should be 3 by 1 what's the
problem of this equation exactly we're
summing a 3 by M matrix to a 3 by 1
vector this is not possible in that it
doesn't work doesn't match when you do
some summations or subtraction you need
the two terms to be the same shape
because you will do an element-wise
addition of them an element-wise
subscription so what's the trick that is
used here it's a it's a technique called
broadcasting
broadcasting is that is the fact that we
don't want to change the number of
parameters it should stay the same but
we still want this operation to be able
to be written in parallel version so we
still want to write this equation
because we want to paralyze our code but
we don't want to add more parameters it
doesn't make sense so what we're going
to do is that we're going to create a
vector B tilde 1 which is going to be B
1 repeated three times sorry repeated M
times
so we just keep the same number of
parameters but just repeat them in order
to be able to write my code in parallel
is this called broadcasting and what is
convenient is that for those of you who
do not do homeworks are in max hub or
Python MATLAB okay so in MATLAB know
Python Python so in Python there is a
package that is often used to code these
equations it's non pipe some people call
it dumpy not sure
so numpy basically numerical Python we
directly do the broadcasting it means if
you sum this three by m matrix with a
three by one parameter vector is going
to automatically reproduce the parameter
vector M times so that the equation
works
it's called broadcasting it make sense
so because we're using this technique
we're able to rewrite all these
equations with capital letters you want
to do it together or do you want to do
it on your own wants to do it on their
own okay so let's do it on their own on
your own so rewrite these with capital
letters and figure out the shapes I
think you can do it at home where we're
not going to date here but make sure you
understand all the shapes yeah
so the question is how is this different
from principle component analysis this
is a supervised learning algorithm that
will be used to predict the price of a
house principle component analysis
doesn't predict anything it gets an
input matrix X normalizes it compute the
covariance matrix and then figures out
what are the principal components by
doing the eigenvalue decomposition but
the outcome of pca is you know that the
most important features of your data set
X are going to be these features here
we're not looking at the features we're
only looking at the output that's what
is important to us
so the question is can you explain why
the first layer would see the edges is
there any tuition behind it it's not
always going to see the edges but it's
often time going to see edges because in
order to detect a human face let's say
you will train an algorithm to find out
whose face it is so it has to understand
the faces very well you need the network
to be complex enough to understand very
detailed feature of the face and usually
this neuron what it sees as input or
pixels so it means every edge here is
the multiplication of the weight by a
pixel so it sees pixels it cannot
understand the face as a whole because
it sees only pixels it's very granular
information for it so it's going to
check if pixels nearby have the same
color and understand that there is an
edge there okay but it's too complicated
to understand the whole face in the
first layer however if it understands a
little more than a pixel information it
can give it to the next neuron this
neuron will receive more than pixel
information it would receive a little
more complex like edges and then it will
use this information to build on top of
it and build the features of the face so
what I'm trying to sum up is that these
neurons only see the pixels so they're
not able to build more than the edges
that's the minimum thing that they can
the maximum thing they can build and
it's it's a complex topic like
interpretation of neural network is very
highly researched topic the big research
topic so nobody figured out exactly how
all the neurons evolved yeah one more
question and then we move on
so the question is how how do you decide
how many neurons per layer how many
layers
what's the architecture of their neural
network there are two things to take
into a consideration I would say first
and nobody knows the right answer so you
have to test it so you guys talked about
training set validation set and test set
so what we would do is we would try 10
different architectures train its train
the network on this look at the
validation set accuracy of all these and
decide which one seems to be the best
that's how we figure out what's the
right network size on top of that using
experience is often valuable so if you
give me a problem I try always to gauge
how complex is the problem like CAD
classification do you think it's easier
or harder than day-and-night
classification so then a classification
is I give you an image I ask you to
predict if it was taken during the day
or during the night and on the other
hand you want there is a cat on the
image or not which one is easier which
one is harder
who thinks cat classification is harder
ok I think people are great at
classification seems harder why because
there are many breeds of cats can look
like different things
there's not many breeds of nights one
thing that might be challenging in the
image classification is if you want also
to figure it out in house like inside
you know maybe there is a tiny window
there and I'm able to tell that is the
day but for a network to understand it
you will need a lot more data than if
only you wanted to work outside
different so these problems all have
their own complexity based on their
complexity I think the network should be
deeper become the more complex usually
is the problem the more data you need in
order to figure out the output the more
deeper should be the network that's an
intuition I think ok let's move on guys
because I think we have about what 12
more minutes
okay let's try to write the lost
function for this problem so now that we
have our network we have written this
propagation equation and I will call it
for propagation phase going forward it's
going from the input to the output later
on when we will do we will derive these
equations we will call them backward
propagation because we're starting from
the loss and going backwards so let's
let's talk about the optimization
problem optimizing w1 w2 w3 b1 b2
Mitri we have a lot of stuff to optimize
right we have to find the right values
for these and remember model equals
architectural parameter we have our
architecture if we have our parameters
we're done so in order to do that we
have to define an objective function
sometimes called loss sometimes cost
cost function so usually we would call
it loss if there is only one example in
the batch and cost if there is multiple
examples in a match so the last function
that let's define the cost function the
cost function J depends on Y hat and Y
okay so Y hat Y hat is a 3 ok
it depends on Y hat and Y and we will
set it to be the sum of the loss
functions Li and I will normalize it
it's not mandatory but normalize it with
one over so what does this mean is that
we're going for batch gradient descent
we want to compute the loss function for
the whole batch paralyze our code and
then calculate the cost function that
will be then derived to give us the
direction of the gradient that is the
average direction of all the the
derivation with respect to the whole
input batch and Li will be the last
function corresponding to one parameter
so what's the error on this specific one
input sorry not parameter and it will be
the logistic loss you've already seen
these equations I believe so now is it
more complex to take a derivative with
respect to J like of J with respect to
the parameters or of L what's the most
complex between this one let's say we're
taking derivative with respect to W to
compare to this one
which one is the hardest
who thinks J is the hardest we think it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
derivation is a linear operation right
so you can just take the derivative
inside and you will see that if you know
this you just have to take the sum over
this so instead of computing or
derivatives on J
we will come compute them on L but it's
totally equivalent there's just one more
step at the end okay so now we defined
our loss function super we define our
loss function and the next step is
optimize so we have to compute a lot of
derivatives
and that's called backward propagation
so the question is why is it called
backward propagation it's because what
we want to do ultimately is this for any
N equals one to three we want to do that
WL equals W L minus alpha derivative of
J with respect to W and BL equals V L
minus alpha derivative of J with respect
so we want to do that for every
parameter in layer 1 2 & 3 so it means
we have to compute all these derivatives
we have to compute derivative of the
cost with respect to W 1 W 2 W 3 B 1 B 2
B 3 you've done it with logistic
regression we're going to do it with a
neural network and you're going to
understand why it's called backward
propagation which one you want to start
with which derivative you want to start
with the derivative with respect W 1 W 2
or W 3 they say assuming we'll do the
bias later W what W want you think that
value one is a good idea I don't want to
do W 1 and I think we should do W 3 and
the reason is because if you look at
this loss function do you think the
relation between W 3 and this loss
function is easier to understand or the
relation between W 1 and this loss
function is the relation between W 3 and
this last function because W 3 happens
much later in the in the network so if
you want to understand how much should
we move W 1 in order to make the last
move it's much more complicated than
answering the question how much should W
3 move to move the loss because there is
much more connections if you want to
compute with W 1
so that's why we call it backward
propagation is because we will start
with the top layer the one that's the
closest to the last function derive the
derivative of J with respect to w1 okay
and once we computed this derivative
which we are going to do next week once
we completed this number we can then
tackle this one oh sorry yeah thanks
yeah once we computed this number we
will be able to compute this one very
easily why very easily because we can
use the chain rule of calculus so let's
see how it works
we're I'm just going to give you a one
minute pitch on on backdrop but we'll do
it next week together so if we had to
compute this derivative what I will do
is that I will separate it into several
derivative that are easier I will
separate it into derivative of J with
respect as something with this something
with respect the w3 and the question is
what should this something be I will
look at my equations I know that J
depends on Y hat and I know that Y hat
depends on Z 3 Y hat is the same thing
as a 3 I know it depends on Z 3 so why
don't why don't I include these three in
my equation I also know that Z 3 depends
on W 3 and the derivative of Z 3 with
respect to W 3 super easy it's just a 2
transpose so I will just make a quick
hack and say that this derivative is the
same as taking it with respect to a 3
taking the derivative of 83 with respect
to Z 3 and taking the derivative of Z 3
with respect to W 3
so you see same same derivative
calculated in different ways and I know
this I know these are pretty easy to
compute so that's why we call it back
propagation is because we use the chain
rule to compute the derivative
w3 and then one I want to do it for w2
I'm going to insert I'm going to insert
the derivative with Z three times the
derivative of Z three with respect to a
two times the derivative of a two with
respect to Z 2 and their relative of Z 2
with respect to W 2 does this make sense
that this thing here is the same thing
as this it means if I want to compute
the derivative of W 2 I don't need to
come to this anymore
I already did for W 3 I just need to
compute those which are easy ones and so
on if I want to compute the derivative
of J with respect to W 1 I'm going to
I'm not going to decompose all the thing
again I'm just going to take the
derivative of J with respect to Z 2
which is equal to this whole thing and
then I'm going to multiply it by
derivative of Z 2 with respect to a 1
times derivative of a 1 with respect to
Z 1 times the derivative of Z 1 with
respect to W 1 and again this thing I
know it already I computed it previously
just for this one so what's what's
interesting about it is that I'm not
going to redo the work I did I'm just
going to store the right values while
back propagating and continue to
derivate one thing that you need to
notice though is that look you need this
forward propagation equation in order to
remember what should be the path to take
in your chain rule because you know that
this derivative of J with respect to W 3
I cannot use it as it is
because W 3 is not connected to the
previous layer if you look at this
equation e 2 doesn't depend on W 3 it
depends on Z 3 sorry like my bad
it depends no sorry what I wanted to say
is that Z 2 is connected to W 2
but a1 is not connected to w2 so you
want to choose the path that you're
going through in the proper way so that
there is no cancellation in these
derivatives you cannot compute
derivative of W 2 with respect to 2 a1
right you cannot compute that you don't
know it okay so I think we're done for
today so one thing that I'd like you to
do if you have time is just think about
the things that can be tweaked in a
neural network when you build a neural
network you are not done
you have to tweak it you have to tweak
the activations you have to take the
loss function there's many things you
can tweak and that's what we're going to
see next which ok thanks